we're living in a fascinating time we're
living in a time where women have money
okay which isn't do you realize how new
that is right that's like 30 years old
or something and there's no blueprint
for how to operate and I think it's
really messing up the power dynamic like
the fact that I can pay my own bills
that's such a big deal for me I thought
that making money was gonna solve all my
problems especially my relationship
problems cuz that when I was in my 20s I
had to date guys that had money because
I didn't have any but now that I make my
own money I felt like it opened up this
whole new pool of broke guys that I
couldn't date before so I've been doing
that they're much nicer and last guy I
dated I paid for everything I paid for
trips I paid for dinners and now that
I've sort of been the man in the
relationship now that I've been in your
shoes I now understand why you guys hate
us it's cuz we owe you so much fucking
money and something happens
psychologically when you start to pay
for someone where you start to hate them
so they hate everything about them you
resent them you start keeping score of
everything they do one day he came home
he was drinking a coconut water
it's like coconut water where did the
Queen of fucking England I better drink
out of the tap like a goddamn man how
about that I mean they nag you they
always need something from you you know
you'd be like you want to go to dinner
I'm like you just ate yesterday do you
have a tapeworm what's the problem I
feel like I now understand why you guys
are we so disappointed in us too because
something happens when you start paying
for someone where you start to get these
high expectations for their behavior
like as soon as I started paying for him
I started expecting him to like do
chores I don't know where like one night
we went to dinner I spent $200 on dinner
the next morning I woke up I was like
this is weird it's 8:00 a.m. and I don't
smell eggs
yeah chop chop bitch mommy's hungry
[Music]
it's tricky I also started noticing all
these like unspoken rules that happen
with the expectations based on who pays
like the expectation if the man pays for
the woman is that she's gonna have sex
with you right but when I was paying for
the man the expectation was I am NOT
gonna have sex with you and we're gonna
stay up all night talking about my
dreams I'm gonna read some horoscopes
tonight bitch and then I saw like all
the insidious like institutionalized
sexism like every time we would go to
dinner the waiter would automatically
give him the check and then he would
fucking take it and then when the way to
relieve he would slide it over to me I
was like oh hell no if you take the
check you're paying you better find
yourself a Groupon real fast
I also get now why people stay in
relationships too long because money
makes makes things stickier like I feel
like I stayed in that relationship three
months too long just cuz I didn't want
to get a bad return on my money because
dating is such a terrible investment
which made me think like I can't believe
we just run around spending money on
relationships that we don't know is
gonna work out it's a terrible
investment I feel like there should be
some kind of insurance in place to
protect us like I feel like dating
should be like checking into a hotel
okay you and I are gonna start dating as
soon as we start dating you have to put
your credit card down three months later
if you want to break up I'll be like
alright well let's look at your bill
yeah you owe me $3,200 or you can't
fucking leave